Hello everyone this video is about the
greatest attacking player in chess history
He was known by many names the magician
from Riga, the pirate of latvia, Fortunes
favorite, the hypnotist and so on. This is
the moment you've all been waiting for.
Top 10 facts about Mikhail Nekhemievich Tal
Number one - Mikhail Tal was born on 9th of
november 1936. He was a Soviet Latvian
chess grandmaster and the eighth world
champions from 1960 - 1961. Widely regarded
as a creative genius and the best
attacking player of all time
Tal played in a daring combinatorial
style. His play was well known above all
for improvisation and unpredictability.
Every game, he once said, was as inimitable
and invaluable as a poem. The Mikhail Tal
memorial has been held in Moscow
annually since 2006 to honor Tal's memory.
Number to - Tal was born in Riga, Latvia
into a jewish family. According to his
friend Gennadi Sosonko, his true father
was a family friend identified only as
uncle Robert. From the very beginning of
his life he suffered from ill health.
Tal learned to read at the age of three and
was allowed to start university studies
while only 15. At the age of 8 Tal learned to
play chess while watching his father, a
doctor and a medical researcher.
Number three
shortly thereafter he joined the Riga
palace for Young Pioneers chess club. His
play was not exceptional at first but
you worked hard to improve. Alexander
Koblenz began tutoring Tal in 1949
after which Tal's game rapidly improved
and by 1951 he had qualified for the Latvian
championship. In the 1952 Latvian
championship Tal finished ahead of his
trainer. Tal won his first Latvian title in
1953 and was awarded the title of
candidate master. He became a Soviet
master in 1954 by defeating Vladimir
Saigin in a qualifying match. That same
year he also scored his first win over a
grandmaster when Yuri Averbakh lost
on time in a drawn position. The opening
Tal used with white for this game was the
Belgrade gambit.  Number 4 -  Tal won a  very
strong tournament at Zurich in 1959.
Following the internalzonal the top players
carried out to the candidates tournament,
Yugoslavia, 1959. Tal showed superior form by
winning with 20 out of 28 points ahead of
Paul Kares with 18,5
followed by Tigran Petrosian, Vasily Smislov,
the sixteen-year-old Bobby Fischer,
Svetozar Gligorić,  Friedrich Olafson and
Paul Benco. Tal's victory was
attributed to his dominance over the
lower half of the field while scoring
only one win and three losses vs Keres.
He won all four individual games
against Fisher and took three and a half
points out of four from each Gligorić,
Olafson and Benko. Number five - In 1960
at the age of 23 Tal defeated the relatively
strategic Mikhail Botvinik in a world
championship match held in Moscow by 12
and a half to eight and a half points
six wins two losses and 13 draws making
him the youngest ever world champion
record later broken by Garry Kasparov
who earned the title at 22. Number six -
Botvninik, who had never faced Tal before the
title match, won the return match against
Tal in 1961 also held in moscow by 13
to 8. 10 wins to 5 with six draws. In
the period between the matches, Botvinik
had throughly analyzed Tal's style and
turned most of the return matches games
into slow wars of maneuver or end games
rather than the complicated tactical
melees which were Tal's happy hunting
ground. Tal's chronic kidney problems
contributed to his defeat and his
doctors in Riga advised that he should
postpone the match for health reasons.
Yuri Averbakh claimed that Botvinik would agree to
a postponement only if Tal was certified unfit by
Moscow doctors. His short reign atop
the chess world made him one of the
so-called two winter Kings, who interrupted
Botvinik's long reign from 19 48-1963
the other
was Smislov, world champion from 1957 -1958.
His highest ELO rating was 2705
achieved in 1980. His highest historical
chest metric rating was 2799
Number seven
12th Round of 24th USSR Championship in 1957:
Mikhail Tal adjourned his game with Boleslavsky in a very difficult position.
Straight after play, Tal went off to a date with a girl!
While the other players were enjoying their sleep, Tal spent the time walking around the streets of Moscow.
Next to the Bielorussky railway station they crossed the road in the wrong place and the policeman arrested them and brought to the police station.
The young lieutenant who was on duty turned to look at them with dissatisfaction and returned to the task he had had to break off ---
he was sitting with a chess board in front of him. Tal glanced at the board and couldn't suppress a smile. The police officer was analyzing Tal's adjourned game with Boleslavsky.
Obviously the adjourned game had been dictated in the evening sports bulletin on the radio.
Tal was unable to restrain himself and commented on a move made on the board. Instead of replying, the lieutenant pushed the board away from him and in a bored voice asked,
"Name?" "Tal." "What, another one?" "You'll laugh, I know," said Misha, "But I'm not another one, but the very man himself." A minute later, they were analyzing the position together.
Tal went home only at 7 am. Despite the help of the police, the game was still lost on resumption.
Number eight - here's an anegdote i read in a
book called Life and games of Mikhail Tal
Tal was playing against grandmaster Vasiukov. They reached a very complicated position and Tal was considering a knight sacrifice
(I know what you're thinking... What else would Tal be considering :) But, to his horror, he couldn't find any good continuations.
Suddenly, he started to think about a Hippopotamus drowning in a swamp. He tried to figure out how to save the poor hypo.
After 40 minutes of thinking about this problem, Tal realized that he couldn't save the poor hypo and that some things simply can't be calculated.
He realized that the knight sacrifice was purely intuitive and it promised an interesting game.
The following day, the newspapers wrote how Tal, after thinking for 40 minutes about the position, managed to calculate all the variations and
win the game with a great knight sacrifice. Little did they know that a poor hypo had to drown for Tal to win the game.
Number nine
Mikhail Tal married three times. In 1959, he married 19-year-old Russian actress Salli Landau.
This marriage lasted for 11 years and ended in divorce in 1970.
His second marriage too did not last long.
He later on married Angelina Petukhov who worked in the Riga Shakhmaty magazine.
He had been a sickly child though he had fairly good health during his youth. He suffered from kidney problems that intensified over time.
He underwent several surgeries over the years and even lost a kidney to his illness.
An eccentric man with a bohemian lifestyle, he became addicted to smoking and drinking which further affected his health.
Mikhail Tal died on 28 June 1992 of a haemorrhage in the esophagus. He was just 55.
And number ten - To understand Mikhail Tal a bit more,
here is what Garry Kasparov said about him:
I worked a bit with Tal. Around 1980, he visited Baku,
we played a couple of training games, and the chess contact wasn't lost until Tal's very last days. There was a blitz tournament in Moscow,
one month before Tal's death. He looked horrible. But Tal was still Tal. In this blitz tournament, I lost my only game to him.
I retaliated in the second round, but the fact was that until the very end, he still had this vision of games.
He was the only one I knew who didn't calculate the lines, he saw them.
We calculate: he does this then I do that. And Tal, through all the thick layers of variants, saw that around the 8th move, it will be so and so.
Some people can see the mathematical formulae, they can imagine the whole picture instantly.
An ordinary man has to calculate, to think this through, but they just see it all. It occurs in great musicians, great scientists.
Tal was absolutely unique. His playing style was of course unrepeatable. I calculated the variants quickly enough, but these Tal insights were unique.
He was a man in whose presence others sensed their mediocrity.
this video was a bit longer than the
rest but Tal is my favorite and I
wanted to pay the great Miša this small
tribute. For new players just starting to
learn about chest and it's great
champions, studying the life and games of
Mikhail Tal is a must. If you enjoyed
this video, be sure to give it a thumbs
up and a comment, and if you're
interested when my new video will be
released, subscribe to my channel and hit
the little bell button after :) And, as the
magician from Riga would say: there are
two types of sacrifices, correct ones and
mine. For the end of this video, enjoy
this rare footage of Tal's first
encounter with Bobby Fischer. see you
next week!